what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things Marvel and MCU I'm your host
Warren Thompson and Deadpool 3 is
getting well underway it's in
pre-production right now with filming
about to begin not too long from now and
it seems like every other day we get a
new piece of information about Deadpool
3. right now Ryan Reynolds is doing
interviews for his movie spirited with
Will Ferrell and of course in all of
these interviews everybody is asking him
about Deadpool 3. and today we have a
super awesome report about Deadpool 3 we
are learning more and more about the
plot as each day goes by and so far
everything that we've heard has been
fantastic we also have some news today
about the Fantastic Four specifically
Emily Blunt and her husband John
Krasinski possibly being Mr Fantastic
and The Invisible Woman recently Emily
Blunt was asked about playing Sue storm
in an interview and we'll talk about
that in this video so let's dive into
all of the recent Deadpool 3 news now
first things first I want to clear
something up because a lot of people
have been asking me recently on Twitter
and on Instagram and in the comments of
my videos if Ryan Reynolds is done after
Deadpool 3 no that is not the case there
have been a few reports going around
that Deadpool was done after Deadpool 3
this was his last Deadpool film and this
came from what he said in a recent
interview Ryan Reynolds basically said
that he's only doing Deadpool the next
two years and some people took that as
I'm only doing Deadpool these next two
years and then I'm done but what Ryan
Reynolds really meant to say was is he
is only doing Deadpool that's the only
movie that he's going to be working on
for the next two years as in he's not
going to work on any other films during
this time so for the next two years he
is only focused on Deadpool so you know
it's going to be absolutely fantastic
because he's already been working on the
script for several years now and now we
have Hugh Jackman joining Ryan Reynolds
in the movie you have questions yes I I
had a lot of questions I'm sure you had
a lot of questions but rest assured
we're going to answer them so you know
what's going to be just one of the best
things ever but to make it even more
exciting we have a report today from
Insider Daniel rpk stay stating that
Ryan Reynolds plans on visiting old Fox
franchises and having them be in
Deadpool 3. of course these are the old
X-Men movies and the Fantastic Four now
I think we all know by now that this
movie is going to be a big multiversal
film recently we've learned that Mobius
from the TVA from the Loki series is
going to be in Deadpool 3. and according
to these reports he's going to actually
be playing a major role not just a side
character now we could speculate and
theorize about what his specific role
could be all day long but we know that
Deadpool is going to be hopping across
different universes and the TVA is most
likely going to be on his Trail because
that's what they do they monitor the
Multiverse and there's a lot of ways the
TVA could be on Deadpool's Trail but I
also think it would be super hilarious
if Deadpool and Hugh Jackman's Wolverine
actually kidnap Mobius and take him
along the ride with them it's definitely
something Deadpool would do and it's
definitely something that would add a
lot of humor to the movie which of
course we know the movie is going to be
about so I I hope the reason that he's
in this movie for a long time is because
they actually drag him along for the
ride and now we've learned that he is
going to revisit other universes like
the old Fantastic Four universes and of
course the old X-Men universes which we
kind of already knew because that's how
Hugh Jackman is going to have to join
him but this is actually insanely cool
because this means that Chris Evans
could actually be reprising his role as
the Human Torch now of course it would
be amazing to see Jessica Alba and the
rest of the cast and crew as well but
obviously since Chris Evans played
Captain America in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe which is where Deadpool is
heading it would be insanely cool to see
Chris Evans back again as the Human
Torch and of course you know Deadpool is
going to break the fourth wall and make
a joke and let's face it this is the
type of multiversal stuff that we've
been waiting for we want to see Chris
Evans be two different characters in the
MCU at the same time thanks to the
Multiverse we want to see Superior Iron
Man we want to see Emily Blunt as Black
Widow we want to see really cool
Multiverse stuff and it looks like
Deadpool 3. is going to take us there
now I'm sure Ryan Reynolds is doing this
just for the jokes just to be funny just
to be meta but at the same time I am
also curious if we are going down the
path of Deadpool kills the entire Fox
Universe if you have read this story you
know how crazy it would be to actually
see in the MCU and I think it could
actually happen and we'll talk about
that in just a bit but first big thank
you to wondering and the official the
Lord of the Rings rings of power podcast
for sponsoring this video now I know a
lot of you like me have watched The Lord
of the Rings the rings of power on
Amazon it's amazing I loved it and since
you're on my Channel right now you
probably love to dive even deeper than
just watching the show and now you can
go deeper into the canals of numenor the
minds of kazadum and more with the
official the Lord of the Rings rings of
power podcast host Felicia Day who many
people probably know and several special
guests provide an inside look at the
groundbreaking series and what it took
to bring Middle Earth to life each
episode of the official podcast features
exclusive interview with the series
showrunner DJ Payne and Patrick McKay
including the very first full breakdown
of the incredible season finale Felicia
also goes behind the scenes with the
cast and crew to bring you jaw-dropping
stories and Easter eggs you won't want
to miss watch the rings of power on
Prime video and listen to all eight
episodes of the official the Lord of the
Rings the rings of power podcast for
free on Amazon music download the Amazon
music app right now to listen to The
Lord of the Rings the rings of power
podcast since Deadpool is indeed in the
fox Universe right now and he is trying
to escape and he's going to go on a
multiversal journey to escape perhaps he
will kill the entire Fox Universe on his
way to the MCU it has been rumored for a
while now that that might be what this
movie is going to be about and Ryan
Reynolds told us what the original plot
was going to be for Deadpool 3 and he
said it was about Logan and Deadpool
taking a road trip together rashmon
style rashaman is a movie about the
murder of a samurai and it's told
through different people's eyes through
their different perspectives and each
one of of them tells the murder a
different way so what could be happening
here is that Hugh Jackman's Wolverine
and Deadpool go across the fox universe
and other universes essentially cleaning
them out killing all of the different
characters for one reason or another
probably due to something Deadpool does
and in the end when they finally make it
to the MCU they both view their Journey
as something very very different
Deadpool would probably view it as them
deserving it or them starting it while
at the same time Wolverine would say no
definitely Deadpool started it and we
had to fight our way out this would be
cool however I really wouldn't like to
see Chris Evans die as the Human Torch
or Jessica Alba die as The Invisible
Woman however I would really love to see
Deadpool revisit the newer Fantastic
Four film the one that people didn't
really like that much and see him kind
of obliterate that Universe both with
jokes and actually physically I think it
would be all around just hilarious and
you know Deadpool would have something
funny to say but speaking of the
Fantastic Four like I mentioned in a
recent interview Emily Blunt was asked
about the possibility of her appearing
in the MCU as The Invisible Woman of the
Fantastic Four and also about her
husband returning to play Mr Fantastic
obviously people have been fan casting
Emily Blunt and her husband John
Krasinski for a very long time but after
Multiverse of Madness spoiler alert
where we got John Krasinski as Mr
Fantastic before he was shredded into
string cheese fans were incredibly
excited to see him and since that
happened we're now all wondering will he
play the main Mr Fantastic in the MCU
and will his wife play The Invisible
Woman but here's what she said in the
interview in an interview with extra TV
they said Fantastic Four rumors everyone
thinks that you would make an incredible
invisible woman that Jon would make a
great Mr Fantastic where do you guys
stand are you guys fans of the MCU could
we see you take on these roles in which
Emily replied well I know nothing so
I'll just say that but I mean I never
know how to answer these questions no
one has approached me about the
invisible woman so we'll just leave it
at that I have not been approached about
the Invisible Woman in which Extra TV
then asked would you be interested and
Emily replied with I don't know I don't
know I'm always very touched by the fan
castings I think that's cool now a lot
of people have seen this and have said
well that does it for Emily Blunt she's
not going to be the invisible woman but
we have to realize that of course she
cannot say if she's been talking to
Marvel Studios about playing the role
but I would say that she probably has
talked to Marvel Studios at some point
about the role because her husband met
with Marvel Studios and was Mr Fantastic
and Multiverse of Madness so they had to
talk about it at least a little bit but
of course when you meet with Marvel
Studios you sign an NDA a non-disclosure
agreement which means you can't talk
about anything that you discuss with
Marvel Studios or you get sued so is
there a chance that Emily Blunt could
still play The Invisible Woman yes is it
likely probably not at this point
because at this point we've had so many
reports from insiders and unfortunately
her name really isn't on the list that
often so is it likely that she's going
to play the visible woman no but it is
still a possibility and I for one would
love to see her play that role since
Deadpool is jumping universes perhaps
they could jump into a universe where
she is the Invisible Woman and maybe
they can make a joke about that Deadpool
3 really does have unlimited potential
they could do whatever they want and you
know Ryan Reynolds will do what he wants
so I'm really stoked to see Deadpool 3.
I'm really excited to see the direction
that Ryan Reynolds will take this and I
have full faith that it's going to be an
awesome film but let me know your
thoughts about all of this in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest news and
for live updates you can always follow
me on Instagram and Twitter as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof
foreign